come on you - oh you buddy afternoon
Ramsey
what a gorgeous drive that was oh thank
you are we the valet parking on strike
eight years this time of year so it's
temporary Bally parking I wouldn't do my
car cuz you kept the sign there I'll
Park it for you how about that
well it's last time we dusted it has bit
dusty what's that that something is
growing up there do you see that or is
it me I'm sorry but I can't see it well
I know you both wearing glasses what
make sure you can see it wow it's not
real easy to see for me how'd you get
that down and where is the pole be right
back Wow now you've made everything
dusty down here I've made it dusty no
you haven't cleaned it yeah supposing
that falls on my customers have what
would you do I don't think it a will
actually but you don't think it'd work
no well it's been up there for about six
months it seems to be growing actually
nice disgusting yeah brats
shame on you I know it Wow and what's in
here more dust over here break no
there's there more you must have missed
that spot - there's a big long yes I see
that Wow we've been closed for the last
three weeks when it's so slow this time
of the year we go on a holiday and when
you close do you normally clean before
you close what you come back does come
back the way it is and wow look at that
of that we're living in a very dusty
environment here that's [ __ ]
okay come on seriously this is mountain
cleaner over there you go yeah thank you
for it I didn't expect a plea as I check
in alone
oh my god there you go they're gross
right don't mess it up too much it's all
gonna come down well how long you think
it'll keep it up very might as well do
them all while we're at it we might as
well do them all yeah it's not funny
I've got to get this thing out here
holy [ __ ] look at that why didn't you
get to that and hello viewer in this
place 15 15 years 15 years you just it
was cleaned it was clean you just good
you've got a great eye I've done lots of
things on arrival but I've never quite
cleaned [ __ ] like that from a scenic
I'll give that back sure how did it get
right yeah what's going on here
on the front door you've got 40 flavors
yes
so no some yes when we're really really
busy we have a line that goes out the
door yes I'm talking about this one
person asked for a sample they will all
ask for example and how do you think all
those yogurt franchises entice business
there for samples so they speculate to
accumulate so no samples though no
samples who comes up with all these
stupid rules it's probably myself man
you like kicking the crap out of the
locals don't you yes so I take it we're
not gonna get oh there's another one
yes there's me thinking that's a flavour
so how long ago do this close oh my God
look at us it's it's not closed this is
not closed no it's not stop it is not it
looks like it's like oh no lanty how
where's this thing on please
oh my god this is monstrous